CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
joins us now to discuss let's pick it up
where molla left off with the victims
and accusers because you really feel for
them they are angry they feel betrayed
and very hurt what recourse do they have
mullah just touched on it well they do
have a great deal of recourse though
certainly not what they wanted which was
to see Jeffrey Epstein in a criminal
court facing the charges of his
allegedly depraved behavior with young
girls who were children so what can they
do what they can do is if they have not
already filed civil suits those who were
sexually abused as children in the state
of New York have a wonderful law that
has just passed this year and ironically
in terms of timing they have a window of
one year no matter how old you are now
and no matter how long ago sexual abuse
occurred while you were a child and
certainly someone under the age of 18 is
considered a child they have one year to
bring a case no matter when it occurred
and that starts Wednesday August 14th
I mean retiming is amazing Ricky what
happens to this case now I mean you
heard there's a conspiracy charge there
was a conspiracy charge attached to
Epstein or his associates likely targets
yes we know they are likely targets it's
not even that we're guessing because the
United States attorney Jeffrey Berman
came out and said that he was going to
continue to go forward and investigate
so we have accomplices co-conspirators
enablers and the big target is a woman
named Ghislaine Maxwell and she is
someone who was Jeffrey Epstein's
girlfriend but other of many of the
victims have accused her of actually
being a procurer who has been someone
who was in the thick of it who managed
all of these properties so she really
has a bull's-eye on us we should we need
to say here that she has not been
charged with anything that Liam Italy
denies it and she's not been arrested
not only that she may be cooperating
there's lots of rumors that she's
cooperating so she's either potentially
the greatest co operator or the greatest
defendant but she's not the only one
other thing is nobody knows where it
seems to know where she is at this
moment well we don't know where she is
at this moment I don't know about the
government what about the money five
hundred and fifty nine million dollars
Epstein's assets apparently could the
accusers ever get that yes there are two
ways that they can get it the obvious
way that they can get it is by filing
their civil suits because those will be
civil suits for damages many of them as
I say have already filed civil suits so
what the first move is by many of these
very very good and assertive lawyers or
breslav lawyers is that they will then
freeze the assets in the estate so that
they cannot be dispersed by the executor
to the heirs or to charities whatever
Jeffrey Epstein may have left them to in
a will if you left a will and still a
lot of questions on how this happened
that jail don't you think has a lot of
explaining to do I think the MC Sam was
in real trouble and fun really heads are
gonna roll on this one the idea that he
was supposed to be watched every 30
minutes wasn't but more important the
idea that he was taken off the suicide
watch to me and to many experts is
inexplicable either negligence or it's
corruption and neither answer is good
I'll take either one the MCC is the
Metropolitan Corrections surgeon yes and
one of the most allegedly secured
facilities on earth Paul Manafort is
still there our chapo was there all
right a lot of questions Thank You Ricky